les maintenant notre collègue pierre
antoine lévy pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
la détresse que rencontrent actuellement
les étudiants fassent l isolement
provoquée par la fermeture des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
le samedi 9 janvier dernier un étudiant
de l'université de lyon iii a tenté de
mettre fin à ses jours en se
défenestrant de sa résidence
universitaire hier soir toujours à lyon
c'est une autre étudiante qui a commis
ce même geste désespéré ces gestes de
désespoir doit nous alerter sur la
détresse que rencontrent les étudiants
actuellement depuis la fermeture des
universités
l'immense majorité des étudiants
considèrent que l'enseignement s'est
dégradée les courants distanti elles
sont devenues insupportables les
étudiants n'en peuvent plus ils
n'acceptent plus d'être infantilisés
madame la ministre ils sont au bord de
la rupture
comme le rappelle éric carpano le
président de l'université lyon iii la
fermeture des universités les cours à
distance l'arrêt des activités sportives
culturelles et festives
on favorise l isolement et la détresse
psychologique avant la crise que nous
traversons c'est l'ensemble de la vie
étudiante qui est bouleversé en plus des
cours on constate que la situation
économique a plongé les plus fragiles
dans la précarité
nous sommes au bord de décrochage massif
qui risque d'entraîner de nombreux
gestes de désespoir comme celui de
samedi dernier et d'hier soir madame la
ministre
les éditeurs bunton cap il était
invraisemblable de laisser les gens sont
entassés dans les métros et d'interdire
la reprise des cours en amphithéâtre
même avec le port du masque
il en va de la qualité de leurs études
de la reconnaissance de leurs diplômes
sur le marché du travail et surtout de
leur état de santé physique et mentale
ma question est simple madame la
ministre face à l'urgence de la
situation et pour éviter une succession
de drames que compte faire l'état pour
apporter une réponse concrète à ses
étudiants en détresse pour vous répondre
la parole et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et d'innovation en à vide vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mais la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs votre question sur la
détresse psychologique des étudiants me
permet effectivement d'adresser toutes
mes pensées aux familles aux amis aux
communautés aux camarades de ces
étudiants qui effectivement dans ces
situations de difficultés souvent multi
cause allaient d'ailleurs des enquêtes
sont en cours à ce sujet et bien
attentes à leurs jours mais dans votre
question je crois qu'il ya plusieurs
choses qui se mélangent d'abord je crois
qu'il faut rendre un hommage vibrant et
appuyé à l'ensemble de la communauté des
enseignants chercheurs et des
enseignants qui dans les universités
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur travaillent d'arrache-pied
pour que justement les cours aient lieu
pour que justement les diplômes de nos
jeunes ne soient pas dévaloriser pour
que justement il puisse être accompagner
au mieux dans cette situation très
difficile pendant ce deuxième
confinement nous n'avons pas fermer les
universités monsieur le sénateur tout
d'abord toutes les salles de ressources
sont restés ouverts ce rendez vous de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent garder les
étudiants puissent garder un minimum de
contact avec lui vers les établissements
ensuite des enseignements ont été
autorisés ce qu'il était impossible de
mener en présentiel
enfin depuis le tout début du mois de
janvier
il peut y avoir pour les plus fragiles
une reprise des enseignements en
présentiel par tous petits groupes par
groupes de dix et ce vendredi nous
allons continuer à travailler avec les
conférences des présidents avec les
conférences des directeurs
d'établissements pouvoir comment est-ce
qu'on peut élargir cela parce que oui
les étudiants les plus fragiles sont
ceux qui entrent dans l'enseignement
supérieur cette année les étudiants en
situation de handicap
les étudiants internationaux qui se
retrouve seul sur notre sol et nous
voyons bien qu'en réalité ils sont très
nombreux
c'est pourquoi nous allons travailler
pour faire de nouvelles propositions
pouvoir faire revenir les étudiants sur
le lieu d'un saignement
c'est très important pour leur avenir
pédagogique et psychologique je vous
remercie monsieur lévy vous avez
quelques secondes
depuis allégées merci madame la ministre
pour les cette liste d'actions et cela
visiblement insuffisant les faits nous
le montrent les étudiants ne doivent pas
être sacrifiées et pour le moment c'est
ce que l'on peut constater il en va de
l'avenir de notre jeunesse je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]